siri які звуки видають свій нікола їх
заганяють до себе в хлів
взагалі не хочу їхати з криму та заміж
ти як тут класно взагалі я звикла
тут як у себе вдома жили настільки всю
душевну по-домашньому ось до чого
накопичити тиснули і не хочу я змушена
виїжджати зі своїми дітьми млинець збирати
звуки глен треба швидше збирати про
садака то я підозрював що можна в
strata 71 година на маля чотири рази за
хвали але зроблю змішані
[музика]
страви
вона
і давно ти мій досвід
дитячий садок the path to the
контакти
бадан до
він знову
[музика]
kuga
через
[музика]
краще та
ти навіщо в ростах ти їх все не буде
крем російською не буде
[музика]
так як
у продавця дали
це не бачить що не робив аеродрому
раптом там недалеко живе в нього каміння то
будинку це нічого не буде
[музика]
що чути про антонівський міст
скажемо так про антонівський міст чутно і
з кожним днем ​​все чутніше не чутніше
місцеві кажуть що йому до але вже
жу-жу-жу жорсткість опор збільшили
тому ван надійний як ніколи швидше
навіть ніколи ніж до куба 4 красуню за
сьогодні
[оплески]
до речі цікавий факт за останні дні
на міст встиг змінити кілька назв
спочатку був антонівський потім став
антонівський ну а прямо зараз його можна
сміливо назвати під бродівський міст
є нашу техніку я так розумію можна
переправлятиме під водою
Правильно навіть під водою вже
перебуває більша частина нашої військової
техніки якої я впевнений у будь-який момент
готова героїчно заіржавіти за батьківщину
стільці скажіть суто теоретично якщо
шанси у вас взяти вас у котел це
малоймовірно по-перше з нашими бійцями
каші не звариш а по-друге при всьому
бажання ну де вони візьмуть такий
величезний котел побачити пару розшуку teen
top
to be добрі до дня добрий тупи
термометра показуватимуть на цю
тиждень до 8+9 градусів
[музика]
датчиків coords we booked вісь та у вухо
Привіт привіт
rost кидаю орка пішло.
шо ти бідолах як тобі квіточки
[музика]
сидить там
але я ніби як
[музика]
огляд
адже ви берете свій сайт гроші
я тебе
настій big as
big as
moshe
makes a big ass big ass off of courage а
ваша вершина за ваше пікасо for you
[музика]
по
вовк
[музика]
хоча в віщуни сновидець знахар
ведун цілитель магістра бурштинової зірки
і маг єдиний представник
діамантовий раз на землі алмаз може і
там наша дорога я вловлюю ультразвуку
бачив посилання вийти теми читаю думки на
вид стане рибою вгору на 20 метрів
давши дружину до 50 можна придбати будь-який за
візи та подряпати і будь-яку кам'янку а за
один раз може бути і 20 кейт не при
вальці бути сказано ще ставків жувати їх
намбі так вам так не будуть
[музика]
так і розумний ви по штабу дошкою той
код вже не мати, а я прочитаю vuitton і
атласова видаляй каміни вони котики круп'є
[музика]
живи довго і процвітайте мою люблю, а то
мені композиції клео пор нуся вибач я
хотів би молодь на слухало російських
писань не говорила російську і на
довелося російських blurry щоб був
душа волоки подарунок для нас українців
солдат